faire le bilan de santé de n'importe
quel animal vous conviendrez avec moi
que c'est jamais facile mais imaginez si
l'animal en question mesure plus de 20
mètres c'est vraiment une prouesse
scientifique des chercheurs californiens
ont réussi à faire
renault va libérer gagner et là pour
nous en parler pour la chronique 300
secondes de sciences bonjour jeunes au
calme
on parle d'une baleine bleue oui les
scientifiques sont allés mettre un
capteur sur le coeur pour capter le
battement cardiaque
oui c'est vraiment c'est vrai une
manoeuvre très difficile qu'ils ont
réussi à faire parce que faut dire que
l'on connaît très peu de choses sur cet
animal on connaît on connaît les grandes
lignes on sait que c'est le plus grand
animal sur terre les plus gros spécimens
mesure jusqu'à 30 mètres et pèse 200
tonnes donc c'est un gigantesque animal
se sont accrochés comme ça de la balle
et oui c'est exactement cela en fait il
voulait étudier son rythme cardiaque à
son carbone ces sanctions coeur c'est un
organe de 200 kilos donc c'est un organe
gigantesque mais on connaît donc on ne
sait pas comment il fonctionne et on
connaissait pas son battement donc pour
réussir à le mesurer les chercheurs
universitaires eux deux sont lancés dans
cette espèce d'épopée ils ont apprises
ont dû approcher la baleine pendant
qu'elle est encore en surface ce qui est
un peu difficile parce que justement 10
à 20 milles autour du monde en ce moment
qui se promène dans tous les océans du
monde donc sont plus difficiles à
trouver a conduit l'approcher pendant
qu'elle est en surface et ont dû aller
accrocher avec une pole un appareil la
taille d'une boîte à lunch et ont dû le
mettre exactement bon endroit pour
réussir à mesurer son coeur et on dit
faire tout ça avant que la baleine
replonge donc ça a été cette année
système beaucoup de chance comme
manoeuvre mais non semaines ont réussi
du premier coup mais ils ont un
enregistrement de 8 heures c'est ce que
donnait les images assez exceptionnel
parce qu'une caméra aussi donc on ne
peut plus suivre la baleine bleue comme
on le voit la danse a plongé donc c'est
ce que donnait ces images là assez
exceptionnel ils ont entendu quelque
chose mais ils ont réussi à mesurer sa
fréquence cardiaque est ce ça c'était
assez surprenant parce que le coeur
d'une grande baleine bleue c'est
incroyablement lent quand elle est sous
l'eau on parle de deux battements par
minute alors que quand elle en surface
ça grimpe à 37,50 est un peu énervé donc
pour donner une idée le sim pour toutes
pendant toute la durée de ma chronique
là-bas le cas la baleine aura battu
douze fois en rire aussi tout alors qu'à
côté c'est un être humain son coeur bat
entre 60 et 100 fois par minute un
animal encore plus petits comme une
souris 6 600 à 700 fois donc c'est
beaucoup plus
exactement plus on est petit plus à
beauvais enfin les chercheurs disent que
ça donne une idée sur pourquoi pas des
animaux encore plus gros que sauf sur
terre parce que plus un animal est gros
plus son coeur doit doit dépenser de
l'énergie pour battre ces dix tonnes de
sens que ça pompe dans cet animal health
care est donc un élément encore plus
grosse rendu là ce serait un rythme
cardiaque trop lent pour que ça marche
même temps ça nous en a pris aussi
beaucoup sur ces baleines là qui sont
passés par l'extinction dans les années
donc plus on peut on en connaît sur
helpe l'on peut les protéger
oui tout cas c'était impressionnant
vraiment est la cop15 ça s'en vient oui
elle avait dit c'est la situation est
assez différente en fait on est loin de
ce qu'on a vu avec l'espèce
d'enthousiastes qu'on avait à l'accord
de paris il ya quatre ans parce que
depuis ces accords là il ya eu très peu
de progrès cette semaine on en a
beaucoup parlé il ya eu six rapports qui
ont montré que les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ont augmenté au lieu de
on voulait que sa déclinaison augmenté
de 1 point 5 % à chaque année depuis la
dernière décennie
donc on va vraiment dans la mauvaise
direction oui c'est en fait à ce rythme
là on s'enligne pour que d'ici 2100 en
hausse de température de 3 points 2
degrés celsius
donc si on veut rester à 1,5 degré de
température moyenne mondiale
il va falloir qu'on baisse aux émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de 7 points 6 %
à chaque année c'est un travail colossal
c'est encore réalisable surtout ici en
tout les scientifiques nous le disent
mais parce que la technologie pour pour
ce faire cette transition la halle
existe mais ça va nécessiter des gestes
concrets et surtout beaucoup
d'investissement et du courage politique
parce que là on voit de plus en plus les
conséquences de l'inaction d'actions
effectivement avec les effets de l'écrit
de la crise climatique on les voit
vraiment partout même qu'un texte été
publiée par des chercheurs dans nature
un peu pour nous mettre en contexte eux
nous expliquer que présentement travers
le monde on est en train de traverser
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle des points
de non retour donc des endroits où une
fois que la situation va changer on
pourrait plus jamais revenir en arrière
et quand on regarde seulement qu on
essaie d'avoir une vue d'ensemble
on voit que tous les problèmes sur terre
son étui écologie compte que son était
relié pour la plupart comme par exemple
la fonte des glaces un bon article se
serrent relâche de l'eau douce dans
l'océan ça ralentit les courants
océaniques
ce ralentissement le ca va avoir des
effets sur la température à la surface
des continents
ça peut dégrader les forêts et tous ces
trucs là ensemble ça favorise la
production de plus de gaz à effet de
serre donc c'est tous des problèmes qui
sont liés les uns aux autres et qui
peuvent empirer la situation dans la
science de faire le lien que c'est
scellier tous ces problèmes on les a
souvent regardés individuellement mais
elle a essayé de regarder cette vue
d'ensemble c'est quelque chose c'est
quelque chose qui compliqué à faire et
qu'on est capable de faire de mieux en
mieux donc les chercheurs ont voulu nous
présenter dans cet article la et de tout
ceci avec des hausses de température
mais ça commence avec des hausses comme
on le versement de 1 degré celsius
donc pour éviter que sa barque ça empire
et qu'on dépasse 2 degrés celsius va
falloir beaucoup de travail à la coop
25,7 symboliser 20 tournées vers la
conférence de louis madrid c'est sûr
lundi on se livre avec des images oui je
voulais finir et des images assez
spécial ça a été capté par un drone au
large du costa rica cette chercheuse qui
a trouvé que vu des milliers de tortues
de mer dans leur migration annuelle donc
c'est ça arrive à chaque année mais une
image on voit autant que tortue c'est
dans ces endroits
c'est exceptionnel on va voir un recul
ici il ya à peu près une tortue père
mètres carrés sur cette image là on
parle de dizaines de milliers d'animaux
sur une surface d'équivalent d'un
terrain de football
donc c'est il espère que la diffusion de
cette vidéo là ça va sensibiliser les
gens à cette spéciale qui envoie
d'inquiétant qui est menacée surtout par
l'industrie du tourisme